[Music]
is this true you have a line of glasses
right you get our plates
yes plates I have yeah this is
dinnerware that I have it's called Vita
and I know no man not many people know
about it yeah I don't think nominee we
are here now yeah we have a line of
glasses and plates right oh yes well of
eyeglasses I have but yes I I just I'm
doing a campaign for Vogue eyewear I'm
very excited about then my plates yes
but it always feels weird to talk about
cuz you don't want to be like the pushy
plate lady like you don't want to be
like the pushy like sales I don't know
but yes I do Conan I do have those lines
yeah I think you should go with it okay
you should like go door to door and be
like you VC yeah exactly
well what made you want to get into
eyeglasses it just doesn't you know I I
know that the celebrities do a lot of
you don't have yeah its of products but
why eyeglass well there's wonderful
sunglasses but then with the eyeglasses
um like the reading glasses I've always
wanted to have a pet like I've always
wanted to you know have you know just
seem smarter you always wanted you
wanted to feel that wanted to wear glass
I really I was it's so silly but I I
just I thought that you know when I was
little the kids in school all the really
smart kids had little glasses on they
look so so cute and so smart yeah anyway
so I would steer you that's so weird to
want glass I mean yeah well would that
strange but I think I used to stare into
the Sun so I could mess up my vision and
my mother I know
so that's crazy just staring at the Sun
yes and so did you damage your eyes
finally like a year ago
you you've been staring at the Sun for
years you've been staring at a Sun it
asks what you're doing to your eyes to
mess them up oh yeah what do you know
when you do the cross the eyes thing and
then your mother says it's gonna stick
yeah it doesn't stick thick by the way
so you were not only staring at the Sun
but you were cross-eyed staring at this
bad that's how it is yeah I can't
believe you did that just because you
could have worn fake uh oh look at that
that's fantastic we just wake right to
that camera without it yeah yeah just do
it oh my god still got it baby